WE ENCOURAGE YOU EVERY NIGHT TO
DO THAT SO YOU CAN FIGURE OUT
HOW, PLEASE DVR.
GOOD NIGHT FROM WASHINGTON.
FROM NEW YORK CITY RIGHT NOW,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: THE GREAT
TUCKER CARLSON, THANK YOU SO.
SIR.
BUCKLE UP, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
I WANT TO START WITH A
THANK YOU, TO YOU, THE VIEWERS
OF THE SHOW AND
YOU CONTINUE TO MAKE THE SHOW
NOT ONLY POSSIBLE BUT NUMBER ONE
IN ALL OF CABLE NEWS.
NOW GOING ON OUR THIRD YEAR, WE
DON'T EVER TAKE IT FOR GRANTED.
WE ARE WORKING HARD BUT THE
GREAT ENSEMBLE CAST HERE TO
BRING YOU THE TRUTH.
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT, EVERY SINGLE
WEEK.
WE CAN REPORT TONIGHT, ACT
NUMBER ONE IS OVER IN SPITE OF
THE NOISE.
ROBERT MUELLER IS OUT, HE HAS
SAID NOTHING TODAY THAT HASN'T
ALREADY BEEN IN THE REPORT.
SO ACT NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
SURROUNDING THE DEEP STATES, THE
PRESIDENT AND ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION, THAT IS ONLY
BEGINNING.
THAT MEANS JIM COMEY, JAMES
CLAPPER, JOHN BRENNAN AND
OTHERS.
THEY ARE TERRIFIED.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE IN BIG
TROUBLE AND WE WILL HAVE ALLOWED
ON THIS THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
PERIOD WHAT WE ARE HEARING FROM
THE DEMOCRATS, PET PARROTS IN
THE MEDIA MOB IS NOTHING MORE,
IDIOTIC NOISE.
ONLY NOISE PER USUAL, ONGOING
HYSTERIA.
NOT ABOUT TRUTHS OR FACTS.
YOU'VE HAD TWO YEARS OF LIES AND
HOAXES AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES
PETALED EVERY SECOND OF EVERY
MINUTE OF EVERY HOUR OF EVERY
DAY.
IT'S JUST ONE MORE ROUND OF
LYING TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND TROMPED BASHING
OVER A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THERE WAS NO TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION,
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
MUELLER HAS SPENT 25 PLUS
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTIGATING A
HOAX AND NOW FOR THE FOURTH TIME
WE HAVE A CONCLUSION.
NO COERCION AND NO CONSPIRACY.
TODAY HE OFFICIALLY RESIGNED
FROM THE OFFICE OF SPECIAL
COUNSEL BUT NOT BEFORE SHOWING
THE WORLD OF COURSE WHAT WE
ALREADY KNOW ON THIS PROGRAM,
HIS PARTISAN HACKERY TRUE COLORS
IF YOU WELL.
WHO IS NOW ALL BUT CHEERING FOR
IMPEACHMENT BASED ON NOTHING.
AND IT, THEY WERE RIGHT THE
ENTIRE TIME.
>> IF WE HAD HAD THE CONFIDENCE
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAD NOT
COMMITTED THE CRIME, WE WOULD
HAVE SAID SO.
WE DID NOT HOWEVER MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME.
THE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES A
PROCESS OTHER THAN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO FORMALLY
ACCUSE A SITTING PRESIDENT OF
WRONGDOING.
>> Sean: NUMBER ONE, MR.
MR. MUELLER DOESN'T KNOW THE
LAW.
ACCORDING TO THE LAW, WE GOT RID
OF THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE JERROLD
NADLER DIDN'T WANT THE CANNON
STARR REPORT WITH 11 SPECIFIC
FELONIES LISTED, EVEN MADE
PUBLIC.
SO THEY CHANGE THE LAW.
THAT MEANS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES UNDER
NADLER AND COMPANIES, WE ALREADY
KNOW THE ANSWER.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, THE
NONPARTISAN OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL, ALL CRYSTAL CLEAR ON
THIS MATTER.
THEY ALL CONCLUDED THE PRESIDENT
DID NOT OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
NOT BECAUSE OF SOME JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT RULE OR GUIDELINE, OR
SOME CONSTITUTIONAL RESTRICTION.
THEY ACTUALLY WERE VERY CLEAR ON
THIS POINT.
BUT BECAUSE THERE WAS NO CRYING.
THEORISTS IS NO COVER-UP.
AND ACCORDING TO A STATEMENT
FROM THE DOJ, THERE IS NO
CONFLICT BETWEEN THEM ABOUT THIS
MATTER.
IN AMERICA WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS
ALWAYS ON THE STATE.
I KNOW THAT WE LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE MEDIA WILL CONVICT A
16-YEAR-OLD KID AND NOT EVEN
MAKE A PHONE CALL TO GET TO ANY
OF THE FACTS BUT THE REALITY IS,
IN THIS COUNTRY WE ARE INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL BASIC
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
AS THE PRESIDENT JUST STATED ON
TWITTER "NOTHING CHANGES FROM
THE MUELLER REPORT.
IT WAS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE AND
THEREFORE IN OUR COUNTRY A
PERSON IS INNOCENT, THIS CASE IS
CLOSED.
THANK YOU.
MUELLER'S CONTINUED PUBLIC SMEAR
OF A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CHARGED WITH NO CRIME IS
COMPLETELY UNETHICAL AND
IMMORAL.
WE WILL EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS IN
DETAIL.
AND MUELLER'S ACTIONS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO IT JUSTICE,
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH JUSTICE
AND HIS PRESSER TODAY SERVED ONE
PURPOSE AND THAT WAS TO HELP THE
DEMOCRATS, YET GIVE THEM ANOTHER
POLITICAL BONE TO CHEW ON.
THAT BONE HAS NO MEAT.
THERE IS NO UNDERLYING CRIME, NO
EVIDENCE OF GUILT.
JUST MORE ANYONE        INNUENDO
JUST MORE ANYONE        INNUEND.
COMPARE THAT TO UNDER THE
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL STATUTE.
KEN STARR ACTUALLY OUTLINED
11 -- LOOK RIGHT THERE --
SPECIFIC CRIMES COMMITTED BY
THEN PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
FIVE COUNTS OF LYING UNDER OATH,
FOUR COUNTS OF OBSTRUCTION.
ONE COUNT OF WITNESS TAMPERING
AND ONE COUNT OF ABUSIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY.
PRESIDENT CLINTON LOST HIS LAW
LICENSE AND HE WAS IMPEACHED, HE
HAD TO PAY PAULA JONES NEARLY A
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE OF THE
SPECIFIC CRIMES UNCOVERED BY
STAR.
YET TODAY WE SEE A MUCH
DIFFERENT PICTURE.
MUELLER IS NOW JUST CHEERING FOR
THE PRESIDENT'S IMPEACHMENT WITH
NO INTENT, NO UNDERLYING CRIME,
AND THE SAME PEOPLE SCREAMING
ALL OVER TELEVISION TODAY ARE
NOT THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD EVER
SAY, HILLARY VIOLATED 18 USC
1793, THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
AND THEN WHEN SHE DELETED THE
SUBPOENAED EMAILS AND THEN SHE
BLEACH BIT'S THE HARD DRIVE, THE
INTENTION WAS CLEAR, TO DESTROY
THE EVIDENCE OF THE UNDERLYING
CRIME.
WHY DOESN'T ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA
EVER POINT THAT OUT?
IF YOU WERE WONDERING WHETHER OR
NOT MUELLER IS OPEN TO THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THIS DEEPLY FLAWED
INVESTIGATION, THINK AGAIN,
WATCH THIS.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO SPEAK
FURTHER ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
OR COMMENT ON THE ACTIONS OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR CONGRESS.
AND FOR THAT REASON I WILL NOT
BE TAKING QUESTIONS TODAY AS
WELL.
>> Sean: BOB MUELLER DOES NOT
WANT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OF JIM
JORDAN, MARK MEADOWS, MATT GAETZ
AND OTHER REPUBLICANS AND HAVE
TO ANSWER FOR WHY HE HIRED ONLY
DEMOCRATIC DONORS, BIG-TIME
DONORS.
WHY, FOR EXAMPLE, DID ROBERT
MUELLER, WHY WOULD YOU HAVE
HIRED HILLARY CLINTON'S FORMER
ATTORNEY FOR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION?
WHY DID YOU HAVE HIRED A MAN
NAMED ANDREW WEISSMANN, YOUR PIT
BULL ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO HAS
NOTHING BUT A LONG TRACK RECORD?
LICENSE TO LIE, SIDNEY POWELL,
WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, OF LOSING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS JOBS IN
THE ENRON CASE.
IT BEING BEATEN DOWN 9-0 IN THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT, PUTTING FOR
MERRILL EXECUTIVES IN JAIL FOR A
YEAR AND THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT.
HOW DID YOU HIRE THAT GUY?
BY THE WAY, HE ALSO ATTENDED
HILLARY CLINTON'S VICTORY PARTY
ON ELECTION NIGHT 2016.
NOT ONE REPUBLICAN DONOR.
BY THE WAY, A HILLARY CLINTON
SUPER FAN INVESTIGATING HER
POLITICAL RIVAL.
WHY DIDN'T MUELLER HIRE ANY
REPUBLICAN DONORS?
WHEN DID HE DETERMINE THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION?
I'D LIKE THAT QUESTION ANSWERED.
WHY WAS HE MORE INTERESTED IN
FAIR AND TAXI MEDALLIONS AND
LOAN APPLICATION THAN HE WAS
ABOUT A DIRTY BRUSH AN DOSSIER
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION THAT
I OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE
PAID FOR AND THEN WAS USED TO
SPY ON THE OPPOSITION PARTY?
THAT, PEOPLE YOU HIRED SAID
SHOULD WIN 100000000-0 THAT
TRUMP WAS LOATHSOME.
AND THEY HAD AN INSURANCE POLICY
JUST IN CASE DONALD TRUMP WINS?
WHY DID YOU HIRE HIM,
MR. MUELLER?
WHY DID YOU HIRED PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE?
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T DO IT AND
WIPED THEIR PHONES CLEAN.
HOW MANY MONTHS TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL PURSUE A PERJURY TRAP,
OBSTRUCTION CHARGES AFTER THE
PRESIDENT WAS CLEARED OF ALL
UNDERLYING CRIMES?
HOW DID YOU HAVE TIME TO GET
INTO A PAIR OF VIOLATION AND
MEDALLIONS AND LOAN
APPLICATIONS?
AT NO TIME DID YOU, MR. MUELLER,
THEY ARE TO INVESTIGATE THE VERY
ROOT OF THIS ENTIRE HOAX?
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER PUT TOGETHER BY A
FOREIGN SPY THAT'S NOT SUPPOSED
TO INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS, WHO
BY THE WAY DOESN'T STAND BY HIS
OWN DOSSIER?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
SUGGESTING LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
DID YOU EVEN CARE THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID A FOREIGN
SPY TO INTERFERE IN    IN THEIR
ELECTION, AND USE RUSSIAN LIES?
DID YOU EVEN CARE THAT YOUR
BUDDY JAMES COMEY USED HILLARY'S
RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO SPY NOT ONLY
ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, AND THEY
SPIED IN OTHER WAYS ALSO, BUT TO
GO BEFORE A FISA COURT AND LIED
BY OMISSION AND NOT TELL THE
COURT THAT HILLARY PAID FOR
THOSE LIES, AND ALSO NOT VERIFY
WHAT WAS IN THE DOSSIER WE NOW
KNOW THAT WAS UNVERIFIABLE
BECAUSE THE GUY THAT WROTE THE
DOSSIER DOESN'T STAND BY IT AND
SAYS HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY IDEA IF
ANY OF ITS TRUE?
I WANT MUELLER UNDER OATH.
I WANT HIM HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I WANT HIM ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS.
IT'S NOW MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER.
SENATOR GRAHAM SUMMED IT UP
PERFECTLY.
IT'S OVER.
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT IS DONE,
COMPLETE, WHETHER THEY LIKE IT
OR NOT.
BUT NOW, ACTS TWO, THE CURTAIN
IS RISING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PHIS WARRANT PROCESS?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU HAVE MY CONCERNS ABOUT
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LACK OF
PROFESSIONALISM IN THE EMAIL OF
INVESTIGATION IS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD ALL LOOK AT?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU EXPECT TO CHANGE HER
MIND ABOUT THE BOTTOM-LINE
CONCLUSIONS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT?
>> KNOWN.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN IN 2016 WAS THOROUGHLY
LOOKED AT IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
>> YES.
>> THE ANSWER IS, NO, ACCORDING
TO BOB MUELLER.
HE COULDN'T DECIDE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION, YOU DID IT, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> DO YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR
CONCLUSION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: DEMOCRATS JUST CAN'T
LET GO OF THEIR TWO YEARS OF
LYING, TWO YEARS OF HOAX, TWO
YEARS OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
NOR CAN THEIR BEST FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB.
AND IT ROBERT MUELLER SPEECH
TODAY WAS FRANKLY JUST ANOTHER
SPARK TO REINVIGORATE ONE MORE
TIME WHAT IS JUST AN IMPEACHMENT
FANTASY.
THEY ARE CLAMORING FOR
IMPEACHMENT MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE.
HERE IS MY MESSAGE TO THEM
TONIGHT.
GO FOR IT.
I WANT YOU TO REACH FOR THE
STARS.
I WANT YOU TO STAY ON YOUR NEW
GREEN DEAL THAT GETS RID OF OIL,
GAS, AND EVERYTHING IS FREE.
AND I WANT YOU TO STAY ON
IMPEACHMENT.
STAY RIGHT THERE AND DON'T SOLVE
ANY MORE PROBLEMS OR SERVE THE
PEOPLE WHO PUT HIM IN
WASHINGTON.
I KNOW MOST ON THE LEFT, YOU ARE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO REALIZE
THAT THE HANDWRITING IS ON THE
WALL.
YOUR REQUEST FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
KIND OF A SUICIDE.
IF DEMOCRATS PURSUE THIS SICK
DREAM OF THEIRS, THE ELECTION IS
GOING TO BE FOR DONALD TRUMP IN
A LANDSLIDE, HE WILL WIN EASILY
A SECOND TERM.
AND AT THE PARTY OF FDR, FOR
PEOPLE LIKE SCOOP JACKSON AND
JOE LIEBERMAN WILL FOREVER BE
MARGINALIZED A RADICAL GROUP OF
SOCIALIST EXTREMISTS THAT DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
OR MAKING US MORE SAFE, MORE
SECURE AND MORE PROSPEROUS.
SO MY ADVICE TO SPEAKER PELOSI
WHO IS SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY,
GIVEN TO THE TEMPTATION, GIVEN
TO THE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
WING OF THE PARTY, AND I THINK
YOU WILL BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY
WILL KICK YOU OUT THE DOOR.
WE KNOW THE REAL SPEAKER IS A
RADICAL FRESHMAN LAWMAKERS.
WHETHER THEY FACE FUNDAMENTAL
TRUTHS, THE RUSSIA HOAX IS DEAD.
MUELLER'S ISSUES IS DEAD AND THE
TRUTH IS IN THE MARKS.
I'M GOING TO SIT BACK AND ENJOY
EVERY NIGHT SAYING, AS WE'VE
BEEN TELLING YOU FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS, HERE IS THE EVIDENCE
BECAUSE IT'S ALL COMING OUT.
THE PRESIDENT, ALL OF IT.